three i want to explain
who the migrants are the composition of
the migrant population and the processes
we follow
first
let me start with the unaccompanied
children
as i think all of you know in the prior
administration
title 42 authority
of the centers for disease control was
used to expel unaccompanied children
regardless of their age and that is a
practice
that we discontinue discontinued
immediately immediately in the biden
administration
for humanitarian reasons because in fact
they are just children some so very
tender of age
these children
are
eligible to make a claim for asylum
or to pursue special immigrant juvenile
status in court proceedings
under our laws
we
in the united states border patrol
transfer them to health and human
services
for their their care custody and control
as quickly as possible to unite them
with a parent or legal guardian here in
the united states before
uh they make their claim for asylum or
their claim for a special immigrant
juvenile status
you will recall in march
of this year
we
experienced a tremendous crowding
in our border patrol stations of
unaccompanied children and i said
then
that it was a challenge for us
that we had a plan to meet that
challenge and that we were executing on
that plan and that it would indeed take
time
that is what we did
and we cleared the border patrol
of the overcrowding of the unaccompanied
children in execution of our plan
next
and of course i should say that of
course we have unaccompanied children
still in border patrol
custody
but we are moving them
much much faster than we did in march
and under the 72
hours
that is required by law next we have the
single adults
single adults the great majority of
single adults are expelled
under the title 42 authority the public
health of
authority of the centers for disease
control
control they are processed very quickly
turned around and sent back if they are
not expelled
they are placed into removal proceedings
which are immigration enforcement
proceedings they are prosecuted for
removal
and are removed unless they make a
successful claim for relief
and establish that they are entitled to
remain in the united states
under the laws that congress has passed
finally the third category
of individuals
are families
individuals who comprise family units
they are expelled under the title 42
authority unless we are unable to do so
for example
in certain parts of mexico they have no
longer any capacity to receive expelled
families and in that instance
we place the families
in immigration proceedings in
immigration enforcement
proceedings for removal to the united
states and they are removed unless they
make a claim for relief under united
states law and that claim is ultimately
successful
we are encountering an unprecedented
number of migrants in between the ports
of entry
at our southern border a few points
we have seen
my surges in migration before
we've seen them in the past and
migration
surges are not new
two
and importantly migrants encountered at
our border are expelled or are placed in
immigration enforcement proceedings
the rise in encounters of migrants at
the southern border began in april of
2020 last year but the increase is most
certainly sharper over the past several
months and greater than in june
allow me
to share with you the cbp enforcement
numbers for july
212 thousand
672 persons were encountered attempting
entry along the southwest border a 13
increase
over june
2021
a majority continue to be single adults
specifically approximately 52 percent
this is a six percent decrease from june
95
788 individuals more than
45 percent of july encounters were
processed for expulsion
under title 42.
116
884 individuals were processed under
title eight
those are removal proceedings
immigration enforcement proceedings as
distinct from
title 42 public health authority
proceedings under the cdc's authority
85
563 single adults or 78 were processed
for expulsion under title 42
with 24
880 processed under title eight
lastly
nine thousand
nine hundred forty eight family unit
individuals or twelve percent
were processed for expulsion under title
forty two with seventy three thousand
eighteen processed under title 8.
these numbers and i think this is a very
important point these numbers do not
reflect the number of different people
who were encountered at the border the
large number of expulsions
under title 42 during the pandemic has
contributed to a large number of
migrants making multiple border crossing
attempts
27 percent of encounters in july were
individuals who had at least one prior
encounter in the past 12 months the
number of unique individuals if you will
encountered in july 2021 was
154 thousand
two hundred eighty eight
a total
of eight hundred forty five thousand
three hundred seven unique individuals
have been encountered year to date
during fiscal year twenty twenty one
compared to
let me repeat that number
845
307 unique individuals different
individuals have been encountered year
to date in fiscal year
one
as compared to seven hundred ninety six
thousand four hundred
seventy nine seven hundred ninety six
thousand four hundred during the same
period in twenty nineteen
there are several reasons for the rising
migrant encounters
at the southern border
worsening conditions of course in the
countries of origin including
poverty a rise in violence and
corruption
young boys whose lives
are threatened
if they decline to join a gang
young women
who are vulnerable to rape
while they walk to school
tragically
former president trump slashed our
international assistance to guatemala
el salvador and honduras
slash the resources that we were
contributing to address the root causes
of irregular migration
another
reason is the end of the cruel policies
of the past administration and the
restoration of the rule of laws of the
of this country that congress has passed
including
our asylum laws that provide
humanitarian relief
and thirdly and importantly is the
resurgence of the economy in the united
states
and the gleam of the american promise
once again
we are facing a serious challenge
at our southern border
and the challenges of course made more
acute
and more difficult because of the covet
19 pandemic
it has also been made more difficult
because of the of the fact that the
prior administration dismantled
our asylum system
nevertheless
we meet challenges we meet difficult
ones we do so with our heroic workforce
our expertise
our plans
and our execution of our plans
here again
just as we did with the challenge of
unaccompanied children
in march of this year
we have a plan
we are executing up our plan
and that takes time
our plan
has four
pivotal parts
addressing the root causes
rebuilding
and building
safe
legal and orderly pathways for migrants
to apply for relief under our laws
without having to take the perilous
journey north
improving security
management processing and other measures
at our border
and attacking the smugglers we've done a
great deal
and we need to do more
we are doing it with our with our
partners throughout the federal
government in an all of government
effort directed
by our president
and we are partnering with law
enforcement community-based
organizations and many others
let me speak of the actions that we have
taken
or at least some of the actions that we
have taken in each part of our plan
first in addressing the root causes
the effort that our vice president is
leading
on her trip to guatemala vice president
harris announced that usaid and the u.s
international development finance
corporation
will provide up to 48 million dollars in
u.s government resources to advance the
economic security opportunity in
guatemala
on july 29th the u.s government launched
our strategy to address the root causes
of migration in central america which
guides our whole of government effort
to improve the security governance human
rights and economic conditions in the
region
usaid already has launched a series of
new initiatives to promote good
governance and expand opportunities that
will enable the people of el salvador
guatemala and honduras to build better
futures
in their home countries this includes
the region-wide 5 million dollar
regional challenge to advance gender
equality in honduras nearly 24 million
dollars to expand employment
opportunities and promote civic and
elective election participation and
integrity
in el salvador nearly 12 million dollars
to help small businesses recover from
the impact of covet as well as new
multi-year solicitations
for up to 115 million dollars to address
crime and violence including gender
based violence and provide opportunities
to youth and others
in guatemala more than 19 million
dollars to strengthen anti-corruption
efforts these are but a few of the
examples of the efforts that are already
underway to address the root causes of
irregular migration
let me speak about what we have done and
what we have underway
to build safe
legal
and orderly pathways
so that people do not need to take the
perilous journey north
on june 10th the u.s government
announced more than 57 million dollars
in funds that support urgent
humanitarian needs of vulnerable
refugees and migrants in central america
the department of state opened the first
migration resource center in guatemala
to provide individuals
with protection screening
and referrals to asylum refugee
resettlement and parole options and i
had the privilege an opportunity to
visit the migration the migrant resource
center in guatemala last month
the president issued a new fiscal year
2021 presidential determination on
refugees that created 5 000 slots for
refugees from latin america and the
caribbean on march 10th our department
the department of homeland security and
state
reopened the central american miners or
cam program to reunite children who are
nationals of el salvador guatemala or
honduras with their parents in the
united states on june 15th we announced
the expansion of the central american
miners program that was a
program that was working and that
president trump dismantled
dhs set aside 6 000 h-2b visas for
temporary non-agricultural workers for
nationals from honduras el salvador and
guatemala on july 29th
last week the u.s government we launched
the collaborative migration management
strategy the first of its kind to
strengthen cooperative efforts to manage
safe orderly and humane migration in
north and central america
we are also as i mentioned
improving processing at the southern
border and implementing other measures
not only to stop recidivism
but to tackle the challenge in other
ways including to strengthen enforcement
we have deployed additional personnel to
the southern border
we have increased lateral flights
of migrants
to address capacity constraints in
mexico
our expulsion flights are now
increasingly moving into the interior of
mexico so return so recidivism is not as
easy we are doing so in collaboration
with mexico
we are prosecuting individuals who have
been previously removed from the united
states because they have unsuccessfully
made a claim for relief under our laws
we are undertaking expedited removal
proceedings
under our law we have in certain
circumstances the ability and the
capacity
to accomplish the removal of individuals
who do not qualify to remain in the
united states to do so more
expeditiously and we are using those
authorities
in partnership with the department of
justice
we are
proceeding in accelerated fashion
with immigration court proceedings to
deliver justice more rapidly without
compromising due process we are working
with mexico
to increase interdictions
i visited mexico with other officials in
the administration but two days ago to
speak about how we can more effectively
partner together and what more they can
do in the context of our overall
relationship as close partners
we have increased our law enforcement
operations in partnership with the
mexican authorities i met again with the
attorney general of mexico as well as
north of the border here in the united
states in an all of government effort
working in task forces both within the
department of homeland security and with
our partners in the federal bureau of
investigation in the drug enforcement
administration and other
law enforcement agencies across the
federal enterprise
we are prepared to do more as the
situation warrants it is critical
that intending migrants understand
clearly
that they will be turned back
if they enter the united states
illegally
and do not have a basis
for relief
under our laws
we are also
at the same time
developing and implementing foundational
changes
to the system
addressing problems that have existed
for many many years that but have never
been solved
in the coming days
our department will announce that we are
making changes and improvements to how
we process asylum claims
we continue to rebuild our immigration
system to ensure fairness and promote
equity
we are expanding the virtual platform
that we used so successfully
to assist the migrants in camp matamoros
which was
intolerable
conditions
we are using that virtual platform
where migrants could
register
using their phones
and we were working with and are
continuing to work with and will
increasingly work with
community-based organizations in mexico
international relief organizations but
like the un high commissioner for
refugees like unicef like the
international organization for migration
to bring in individuals in a safe
orderly and humane way
when in fact they make a claim for
relief under united states law that the
law recognizes
we are also of course addressing the
detention conditions here in the united
states and of course i think you're all
aware of the measures we've taken in
that regard and we will continue to take
the measures that the situation warrants
as i mentioned earlier the covet 19
pandemic presents a unique
and significant challenge we are seeing
an increase in positivity rate among the
migrant population
we built
an architecture to test and isolate the
migrants who make a legal claim for
asylum
with respect to unaccompanied children
they are tested and cohorted on intake
before we move them as rapidly as
possible to the shelter of health and
human services with respect to families
we continue to operate centers where
families are tested
and isolated as needed
we are working and have established
a system with
non-governmental organizations in the
communities
to test and isolate family
members
as the situation warrants
and as i mentioned earlier
the predominant majority of single
adults are expelled rapidly from the
border patrol
now of course the delta variant
makes the situation more difficult our
capacity to test
isolate and quarantine the vulnerable
population that makes a legal claim for
asylum
is stretched
the rate of positivity among the
migrants
is at
or lower than the rates
in our local border communities
as has been expressed by the medical
professionals
this is a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
we are building new capacity to address
the situation and we are doing so as
rapidly as possible
the extent of the challenge
should not be understated
but nor should our ability to meet it
thanks to our workforce our expertise
our plans
and our execution of those plans
our mission
is to protect the american public
and to administer the laws of our nation
consistent with that
our efforts
will uphold our laws
and will uphold our values
that includes
the laws of humanitarian relief
as well as the laws of enforcement
we will work relentlessly
to thwart illegal immigration and to
adjudicate asylum claims fairly
and efficiently
both
are embedded in the law
and we are committed to upholding both
as we work to meet
these long-standing challenges
we do not turn
our backs on our values
our principles
our humanity
and our proudest traditions
with that
let me turn it over
to chief raul ortiz of the united states
border patrol thank you
thank you mr secretary and uh thank all
of y'all
you know what we've seen today
is certainly been an opportunity for the
secretary to meet
with our men and women
that are out there on the front lines
we've met with our board patrol agents
our volunteer force our other agency
partners
the secretary and the rest of the
leadership were able to meet with our
sheriffs and our dps state partners as
well as our elected officials from
county and local governments all the way
from del rio to the rio grande valley we
recognize that here in south texas we
are responsible for about 60 percent of
the illegal migration traffic that
happens along the southwest border and
so it is incumbent upon us to ensure
that we have the necessary resources to
combat both my illegal migration as well
as those other threats that we are
experiencing on a daily basis uh
secretary i am grateful that you have
allowed me to lead the men and women
i'll be the 25th chief of the united
states border patrol and i take that
responsibility with tremendous pride not
only in what i'm going to be able to
provide
and support for the men and women of the
united states border patrol but as well
as to be able to advocate for those
resources that are needed
here in south texas and across the 2 000
miles as well as our northern border and
our coastal sectors you know one of the
things that we heard significantly today
is that you know the impacts to these
border communities and we are continuing
to add as much capacity as we possibly
can as the secretary mentioned we have
moved more virtual agents here in south
texas and we are continuing to shift our
resources against those threats that we
are experiencing on a daily basis
i was mentioning to the secretary
earlier when i was a young agent back in
1996 brownsville was the busiest place
in the country and we have managed to
turn that around we will do the same
thing with this current migration that
we are experiencing at this time we will
have an opportunity to certainly impact
but we're going to do it in a humane way
and we're going to do it with tremendous
dignity not just for the populations
that we are encountering because it is a
complex situation the demographics of
the people that we are encountering are
much different than when i started 30
plus years ago what we're experiencing
now with unaccompanied children family
units migrants from uh countries that we
traditionally don't experience these
tremendous flows from or what our border
patrol agents are faced with each and
every day and then you compound that
with this covet threat at any given day
i may have between 300 and 400 border
patrol agents that are in a quarantined
status and as you know you know i wear
this black uh badge over my back the
black band over my badge because we've
lost eight border patrol agents in the
line of duty to covet or uh to other
events
and one
is too many
and so as we talk about migration there
are other threats that exist out there
our border patrol agents are working
tirelessly in between the front lines we
have seen increases in seizures and
methamphetamines fentanyl
cocaine and just over the last week in
this sector alone
agents
falfurious checkpoint
78 pounds of cocaine
those that's cocaine that would have
made it into our inner streets had it
not been for the diligence and hard work
of the men and women of the board patrol
two nights ago
our agents encountered
10 individuals trafficking
methamphetamines across the river
had those agents not been out there in
between the
ports of entry working in the hours of
darkness
under tremendous stress
those seven backpacks would have made it
into this u.s and we know that we have
an opioid epidemic so on top of dealing
with the tremendous flow that we're
experiencing right now our agents
continue to go out there and perform
their border security national security
mission each and every day and they do
it with
tremendous pride
and i couldn't tell you enough that you
know the professionalism exhibited by
those border patrol agents is amazing
and one of the things that the secretary
was able to convey to him is that to all
of them is that he's going to continue
to work hard to make sure that they have
the necessary resources to perform their
mission we're going to get more
technology out there in between those
ports of entry and we're going to ask
for more agents so we can ensure that we
have the right amount of personnel
technology and a good strategy to take
the fight to the cartels and continue to
make sure that we dismantle these
criminal organizations before they make
it to the immediate border area thank
you very much and thank you mr secretary
for your support
thank you mr secretary cbs news went
inside and zeldus park where a tent city
sprung up overnight because a public
park outside is the only available
option left for local officials and ngos
now scrambling to test and quarantine
families released from u.s custody the
mcallen mayor told us reminded us
immigration is a federal responsibility
the head of catholic charities here in
the rio grande valley says she wants the
federal government to tell her we'll
take over here is there a plan to deploy
federal resources and personnel fema or
national guard boots on the ground for
instance to test and quarantine migrants
released from federal custody and what
is your message to local leaders issuing
local disaster declarations because
they've run out of options during this
pandemic so thank you very much i
visited the park
earlier today i met with sister norma
and other individuals who are doing
extraordinary work there
we of course
in the federal government do
testing isolation and quarantine we work
with non-governmental organizations as
well and we set up an architecture dr
pratesh gandhi has done an extraordinary
job over a number of months
where we are able to reimburse the
non-governmental organizations for the
expenses that they incur
in
testing and isolating and quarantine if
and as necessary of the migrant
population
the park
is outdoors it is uh
the safest
way in which we can accomplish that
testing in isolation in an outdoor
setting and those individuals
are tested positive and we're working
very carefully with sister norma and we
had a discussion earlier today and i
will be meeting with her later today as
well
to discuss the mechanics and what more
we can do it's a very successful
partnership and we have to devote more
resources to it and we will
uh secretary thank you for this
conference
so you mentioned that the u.s has
started to send migrant central american
families deeper into mexico as a
strategy to prevent them from traveling
north again
is this part is in response to the
pushback that mexico has uh has that
you've experienced at the uss experience
in receiving some of those title 42
families or is this uh does these
changes reflect uh some of the new
international coordination to stem
migration
so this is a response to
something that i referred to in my
opening remarks
which is the fact that we are seeing a
significant amount of recidivism
in the context of individuals who have
been expelled under the cdc's title 42
authority they have not been placed in
immigration enforcement proceedings
under title 8. instead we use the title
42 authority
to basically turn them around but if in
fact they are turned around and placed
in the northern uh part of mexico it is
too facile too easy for them
to return and try an illegal entry again
and so in response to that recidivism to
deter and prevent that recidivism from
occurring
we are expelling them further into the
interior of mexico where it's far more
difficult to try again
victor with voice of america how many
flights and how many people have been
uh taking place over the last week or a
month uh sending them back to tapachula
and uh how is mexico responding to
sending central americans into within
mexico i guess so so i will have to get
back with
to you on the specific data with respect
to the number of flights but what we are
doing in terms of our enforcement
efforts is in in collaboration with
the mexican government
for the second time
i traveled to mexico
but two days ago to speak about the need
to increase the number of flights into
the interior of mexico to deter that
recidivism
we are
speaking with mexico in the context of
our overall relationship not just on
issues of migration but on issues of
economic partnership such a significant
trade and travel partner of ours one of
the one of the most significant trading
partnerships in the world
in the in that context we're speaking
about uh what greater interdiction
efforts they can employ to stem the flow
and we
we are of um like minds in that regard
thank you uh telemundo network secretary
i want to know what is your perception
about the
migrant crossing in this moment increase
the number but
consider it is very serious the problem
and the second question is just been in
mexico
do you have a
special agreement with mexico talking
about the title of 42
i wasn't uh so forgive me i'm not sure i
caught your first part of your question
but i will say this about
my two trips uh to mexico
the partnership is extraordinarily
strong
we have a shared interest
in
enforcement and we have a shared
interest in humanitarian relief
the fact that those two
are coexist
uh in addressing uh this challenge makes
it that much more complex
we
will stop illegal immigration that is
our responsibility
at the same time individuals who qualify
for humanitarian relief
under united states law
laws that congress has passed
will be granted that relief we will not
turn our back on the laws of
accountability nor on the laws of
humanitarian relief
thank you so much secretary for taking
my question anastasia bolton uh kens 5
in san antonio
how do expulsion flights to southern
mexico comply with our asylum laws and
administration's verbal commitment that
you reiterated today of a humane
immigration system because the
administration is dropping people off in
the middle of mexico they have no
resources and no way back home thank you
so we are
working with mexico to ensure
that the individuals
who are subject to the expulsion flights
their needs are addressed
we have a responsibility
under the public health authority of the
centers for disease control
to protect the american public we are in
the midst of a pandemic a pandemic that
has not only gripped this country as i
think we all know but has gripped the
world and it is in the lawful exercise
of that public health authority that we
are executing those expulsion flights in
the service of the public health not
only of the american public but of the
migrants themselves
thank you good afternoon mr secretary
it's a little hard can you hear me good
afternoon mr secretary question want to
revisit the coveted testing uh
conversation that you had a little bit
earlier there are some communities like
laredo that do not have ngos that have
set up testing ability and there's some
push back that's starting to begin from
those communities who are refusing to
accept migrants from say the rgb family
units who are being sent because they
are showing a coveted positivity rate
can dhs test those my family units prior
what are you doing to alleviate that
concern in that in those areas
i'm glad you asked that question
because this is an area of significant
focus of ours we have built an
architecture
the fact of the matter is there are
communities that have greater capacity
than others uh some communities have
greater non-governmental organization
capacity than do others and we are
building new processes to make sure
that the migrants are tested
cohorted during transportation isolated
and quarantined as necessary and we are
surging federal resources to address
that need
thank you so much thank you all very
much for joining us
you